hey why do you think the internet is so
quick to believe the women because
that's why this world this world is
getting demasculated but sorry continue
your question no that's go ahead go
ahead why are they so quick to believe
women because women because women are
these delicate creatures that we must
protect but at the end of the day women
also have been at the you know I'm
saying at the very center of a lot of
allegations to where you have to be
proven innocent after you they think
you're guilty like Emmett Till like that
you know what I'm saying you have
situations where women are able to make
crazy allegations and then they're
proven guilty until you know what I'm
saying yada yada takes five years later
and then he's moving and then nothing
happens to the female so we have this
culture to where the women is put on
this High pedestal make sure she's safe
make sure she's this in the court of law
and then we'll figure out what's up
later that's why I think the internet is
so quick to believe women out there